the some LSD was the shortcut to
spiritual enlightenment to others it was
a dangerous hallucinogen and it's been
illegal since the 1960s but now it's
making a comeback in small regular doses
that alter the mind without the acid
trip julienne a therapist at the
psychedelic society used a derivative of
LSD before buying it was made illegal
1/10 of a full dose every three days
before she left for work it feels quite
similar maybe to a cup of coffee so the
effects I would describe because they're
not very gross the very subtle and it
more feels like a cosmic cup of coffee
it helped me to focus it helped me to
feel more motivated in essence it helps
me to access the reservoirs of my
creativity and my motivation micro
dosing is being driven by people sharing
their experiences on social media but
now scientists and the Dutch town of
Maastricht are testing the claims in one
of the first research programs of its
kind Sky News was given privileged
access first they're comparing micro
doses of LSD with placebo to confirm
whether the effects are real or all in
the mind
future studies will test whether the
drug rewires the brain in patients with
mental health problems so a current and
depressive state you may fall back on on
richard habitual thinking and you may
have lost some of the flexibility that
is really needed to cope with any
day-to-day operations and treatment with
psychedelics may actually bring this
flexibility of your mind back this is
activity connectivity amanda fielding
runs the Beckley foundation which set up
the study brain scans already shows
psychedelics increased brain activity
the question now is whether they're more
effective than conventional drugs such
as antidepressants
but you need them I mean we're we are
heading fast into an epidemic of mental
health they're just incredibly valuable
would you like gift of the gods of
nature and we've made a terrible mistake
in making them to mood and criminalizing
them the home office said it has no
intention of legalizing illicit drugs
even if the Dutch research shows small
doses of LSD have a medicinal effect for
the advocates of micro dosing that's
only half the battle
Thomas More Sky News